today is film courage interview i rated
it 5 star fish and it's terrific hello
everyone karen warden will encourage the
radio show we just finished our
wonderful interview with movie reviewer
Perry chin and Paris mama she mission
and we have some additional questions we
want to ask them but we didn't get to
cover a while on the air and I think the
main one that i actually have for myself
actually is you know so many people come
to this town they come to LA and they
try and land the agent and the manager
and do the traditional route of getting
the headshots and taking the classes to
me it seems like throwing a dart at a
dartboard and seeing if you'll get lucky
but I admire what you've done you've
taken matters into your own hands you've
been proactive and you've created this
wonderful brand tell us what are the
pros and cons of doing it you know each
each way or or how did you how did you
come at the realization that really that
traditional route trying to get parried
agent just probably wasn't the way to go
that's a great question Karen so my
journey shows that you really have to be
creative and think outside the box
originally when we got period first
reviews it was really an innocent
outside with school activity that I just
want him to get more challenge because
he's reading at such advanced level but
then because he became so good and I
thought that his reviews has the quality
of being published and then soon enough
people responded newspaper wanted his
column so I saw that instead of going to
an agent which would be too early
because you need me to lay a solid
foundation and to do it long enough
before people will be interested in you
also I felt that I have been someone
with quite a bit of media PR experience
during biotech work I know how to work
with the media I have a good sense of
what kind of stories would be of
interest to them so I thought instead of
you know hiring people to do this I know
how to do it myself why don't I just do
that so I think once a Perry God
national attention and what the CBS News
feature I know that it's a major major
story that will generate interest over
time and as he blossomed with his
creativity and his other artistic
endeavors there'll be a lot more
interesting things to say and to cover
so it's a story where the so-called long
legs if you will and so I thought for
others in the entertainment industry
especially those who are starting out
you may not get much traction if you go
the traditional route to find an agent
yeah you may find an agent get some
small parts but it's up to you to really
actually manage your own career and do
something unique and special the media
always love story that are unique and
special because it's not something
they've seen before and I know a lot of
other kids who are very accomplished
their mom or dad's or parent
also took on similar roles like me to
pitch to the media directly about their
kids story because kids story if they
are positive and inspiring always
generate great interest in the media so
I think for actors & others is the same
thing that if they can do that
proactively then they will probably have
higher rate of success and in the
meantime it doesn't hurt to have an
agency and then the better you do for
yourself it will you will make the
agents work a lot easier because you're
establish your end and it would be
easier for them to pitch you to other
film projects Larry do you have any
response to them yeah real with my mom I
think she is pretty creative in her own
sense
Oh